la prospective parisque monsieur Bab ça
fait c'est pas votre première devant la
prospective et d'ailleurs vous aviez
déjà travaillé un un rapport que que
j'avais coécrit sur numérique et gestion
de crise et qui va m'amener justement à
à vous demander aussi et on avait bien
vu au au cours de ce travail que le et
au regard aussi des critiques qu'il a
généré ensuite que finalement le plus
dur quand on traite de numérique c'est
l'acceptation par les citoyens de ses
outils et de l'usage qu'on peut en faire
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui dans
notre thème Ia et service public va
forcément être à à questionner puisque
on peut avoir plein de bonnes idées si
jamais elles sont pas acceptées par les
citoyens si on n'arrive pas à
démystifier le fait que le numérique
serait je sais pas entrave la liberté ou
autre on on aura fait tout ça tout ça
pour rien alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
choisi de vous faire revenir c'est parce
que vous êtes vraiment un expert de ces
questions
puisque vous êtes actuellement
co-président du Conseil national du
numérique depuis
2021 donc vous vous intéressez au
numérique mais aussi maintenant à
l'intelligence
artificielle vous avez pas mal écrit he
et notamment en 2020 refondre les
politiques publiques avec le numérique
alors malheureusement vous audition
peut-être un petit peu trop tôt puisque
le comité de l'intelligence artificielle
générative qui a été mis en place par la
première ministre au mois de septembre
va rendre prochainement ses conclusions
mais je pense que vous pourrez pas nous
les dévoiler il faudra qu'on qu'on qu'on
les qu'on qu'on les lise mais peut-être
que vous pouvez quand même nous donner
quelques quelques idées quelques
quelques fils conducteurs et puis
surtout vous venez aussi là en ayant un
peu cette cette histoire de du numérique
euh puisque vous avez aussi écrit enfin
c'est même votre dernier livre comment
les ipis Dieu et la science ont inventé
internet alors rien que le titre ça
suscite tout de suite un peu de de d'un
interrogation en mettant sur le même
plan l'p Dieu la science pour donner
internet donc moi je vais prolonger la
question comment d'internet on en est
passé à l'intelligence artificielle à
chat GPT et à plein d'autres choses et
peut-être aussi on n'est pas forcément
tous très familiers des différentes
catégories d'intelligence artificielle
donc si vous savez nous donner la
différence entre le machine learning les
l'intelligence artificielle générative
les LLM on sortira beaucoup plus érudi
de cet après-midi
merci
euh merci beaucoup de vous être rendu si
nombreux à cette audition c'est un
plaisir d'être parmi vous
et peut-être un peu de mise en contexte
eu pour vous permettre de comprendre
d'où je parle je suis avant tout un
entrepreneur j'ai monté des entreprises
pendant 30 ans euh dans le le domaine du
numérique et puis il y a une dizaine
d'années j'ai décié de faire un pas de
côté et je me suis mis à m'intéresser
aux enjeux de euh
finalement du numérique et du numérique
son rapport avec la société je l'ai fait
dans différents cercles je travaillé 10
ans au sein de l'Institut montagne je
travaillé à la Commission européenne
j'étais prof longuement à
sciencecesp évidemment au sein du du
Conseil national numérique je pense
important d'ajouter que j'ai également
je donne des cours à
l'INP et j'ai écé un ouvrage qui
s'appelle politique publique et
numérique intelligence artificielle et
territoire
eu le le sujet connaît une accélération
spectaculaire avec l'émergence de de
chat GPT je pense que la principale
principal facteur qui est derrière c'est
non pas l'avènement ou plutôt
l'invention d'une nouvelle technologie
mais c'est plutôt son avénement
c'estàdire que cette technologie elle
était surétagère depuis 2017 et elle
s'inscrit dans un
continuum où on va dire que depuis à peu
près 2005 2006 il y a une succession
d'innovation qui fait que euh cette
technologie devient tout à fait tangible
euh et les questions qui qu'elle soulèv
sont des questions assez pertinentes en
général c'est-à-dire euh son impact sur
la société sur les systèmes productifs
évidemment sur l'état et son son
évolution à à à moyen terme alors le le
qu'est-ce que c'est cage générative donc
générative découle d'un papier qui est
paru en
2017 qui s'appelle en anglais attention
is all you need l'attention est tout ce
dont vous avez besoin et qui une vraie
rupture dans la connaissance et l'état
de l'art de cette technologie en partant
du principe qu'on est capable de traiter
des ontologies très larges pour vous
donner une idée les les grands modèles
en général s'appuient sur des quantités
d'apprentis sage c'est
250000 sites web c'est à peu près de PTA
oct données si vous faites pour vous
représenter ça de façon
physique si vous mettez ça dans des
disques durs c'est à peu près 2 m³ et
demi de de de disque dur
c'est une somme de de quantité de choses
qui
est absolument impossible à se
représenter c'est je crois quelque chose
comme 800 fois l'aller-retour de la
Terre à la Lune en en en document écrit
en mode académique voilà c'est c'est
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de quantité
de données euh
et le c'est d'ailleurs l'un des
problèmes c'est-à-dire que lorsque vous
avalez des quantités de données aussi
astronomiques vous avalez aussi des
données que vous ne souhaitez pas avaler
et qui sont l'une des raisonss mais pas
la seule de ce phénomène dont vous avez
peut-être entendu parler qu'on appelle
les hallucinations c'est-à-dire des
réponses qui sont fausses en réalité et
qui sont une limite forte pour l'instant
temps à l'émergence de ces technologies
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut
finalement se poser beaucoup de
questions à l'égard de de cette
technologie à mon avis il y a plusieurs
sujets il y a le sujet du système
productif et là très
clairement ce que l'on observe les
travaux qui sont effectués pas encore
tellement par la sphère académique mais
quand même un peu mais beaucoup par des
grands cabinets de consulting de type
mckinse BCG c'est que on a manifestement
des gains de productivité qui sont très
importants qui nous font
face aucune technologie
récente n nous a procuré ces gains de
productivité à commencé par internet
internet est une déception comme le
disait Robert Gordon qui est prix Nobel
de l'économie en
1986 en français je vois des ordinateurs
partout sauf dans les statistiques de
productivité et effectivement jusqu'à
aujourd'hui on peut pas mes mesurer en
macroéconomie l'impact d'Internet et de
l'informatique dans la productivité et
donc on peut pas considérer que c'est
une révolution comparable finalement à
l'électricité au moteur explosion et
toutes les inventions de du du 19e et du
du 20e siècle de ce point de vue-là le
machine learning qui est le corpus
principal de l'intelligence arelle c'est
95 % de ce que vous observez euh en
intelligence artificielle à commencé par
les les mod mod génératif qui sont
autrement appelés des larges langages
modèles c'est du machine learning c'est
c'est quelque chose qui a d'abord
découle d'une grande phase
d'apprentissage celle où vous assimilez
C ces 250000 sites web au sein de votre
modèle et puis
après d'une phase
complémentaire qu'on appelle
l'apprentissage continu qui est la
conversation que vous avez à la machine
qui lui permet de continuer à apprendre
pas toujours d'ailleurs dans les bonnes
directions euh mais
cette cette
discipline nous promet des des gains de
productivité qui sont sensiblement
importants et qui nous poussent à
repenser complètement notre modèle
productif et j'insiste là-dessus ça
n'est pas un incrément c'est-à-dire que
si on essaie de forcer le modèle et de
faire en sorte que ce soit les modèles
de machine learning qui s'adaptent au
système productif on ira vers des
grandes déceptions si au contraire on
essaie de repenser le système productif
pour faire en sorte que h finalement il
bénéficie de de de de ces technologies
on peut avoir des gains de productivité
qui sont assez important alors j'ai pas
le temps de vous faire un exposé précis
des raisons de pourquoi est-ce que ça
fonctionne comme ça mais je pense qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que le système
industriel et l'air industrielle dont à
mon sens on est en train de sortir elle
est bâti sur deux choses c'est la
division scientifique du travail c'est
le fait qu'on spécialise des tâches et
que ces tâches sont quasiment autonomes
les unes des autres et que la valeur est
créée de cette façonlà et puis sur un
système de management qu'on appelle
command and controlle de commande et de
contrôle euh et ça ça découle de
l'origine de la première révolution
industrielle c'est que quand on a fini
les guerres napoléoniennes au
Royaume-Uni on décommissionne l'armée
britannique et c'est le moment où on
commence à avoir des grandes unités
productives
manufacturières 500 1000 2000 3000
personnes et les seules expériences de
grandes organisations que l'on a c'est
celle de l'armée et ce sont finalement
les militaires gradés qui vont organiser
le système productif britannique et par
extension le système productif
occidental et par la suite le système
industriel global et donc c cette
culture elle parvient jusqu'à nous mais
elle est aujourd'hui déclassée par un
modèle en plateforme c'est c'est-à-dire
où ce qui est important c'est d'arriver
à avoir une intégration transversale
multisyo et qui fait que vous arrivez à
synchroniser vos chaînes de valeur vos
supply chaîn de façon beaucoup plus
efficace et vous avez des gains de
productivité qui sont très importants
c'est le cœur du modèle Tesla la raison
pour laquelle Tesla arrive à s'attaquer
à finalement un modèle d'affaires qui
est l'un des plus réputé qu' soit celui
de l'automobile ou finalement il y a des
niveaux d'optimisation qui sont énormes
du fait de taille critique qui ont été
créés par des sous-traitants par des des
agglomérats de de constructeurs
automobiles c'est parce que il a adopter
ce modèle plateformisé aussi bien qui
synchronise les SCADA les outils de
production industrielle et puis qui
synchronise l'ensemble des chaînes de
valeur à très grande échelle ce modèle
est très incompris dans en Europe
actuellement quelques régions qui s'en
en parent le melsland regarde ça les
distri le nord de la Lombardie
s'intéresse également à ça la France qui
pourtant a des des acteurs assez
importants euh dans les systèmes
industriels des Schneider des chiveliles
et d'autres et plutôt en retard
là-dessus et je pense que c'est c'est
effectivement une bonne idée de faire
des des plans d'investissement de type
France 2030 la notion écosystémique basé
sur l'intégration de données et
l'intelligence artificielle est très
structurante dans le modèle productif de
de de main et l'impulsion des pouvoirs
publics n'est pas la moindre des choses
qui permet de réussir là-dessus je suis
généralement pas très colbertiste mais
force de reconnaître qu'il y a besoin de
faire en sorte que il y ait des logiques
de de filière d'écosystème qui soi
structuré donc ça c'est pour le le
premier aspect le deuxième aspect c'est
l'aspect social question de se poser
finalement quel est l'incidence que
peuvent avoir ces technologies sur la
sphère sociale d'abord il y a il y a un
point qui me semble un point de d'ordre
général et sur lequel moi je suis
particulièrement sensible c'est
finalement une sorte de diffraction qui
n'a pas attendu l'intelligence
artificielle pour s'exprimer entre les
territoires et les métropoles donc il y
a tout un tas de travaux qui mettent en
évidence cette dynamique il mon que
finalement les métropolitains c'est des
gens qui parlent anglais qui sont à
l'aise avec la globalisation qui ont
fait des études supérieures et et qui
sont plutôt dans des activités
tertiaires et les territoriaux c'est
plutôt le contraire cette ce chisme en
train de s'accroîre il est pas unique à
la France mais il est très propre aux
nations qui sont très désindustrialisées
je nous apprends rien vous disant que la
France caractéristique qui est vraiment
notable dans les pays de l'OCDE c'est
d'être passé de 24 % de PIB industriel à
10 aujourd'hui aucun notre pays n'a
connu une décroissance industrielle
aussi forte et c'est un très fort
marqueur du vote
populiste que quand on superpose la les
zones de
désindustrialisation on trouve souvent
une forte proportion de votre populiste
et l'industrie ça comme caractéristique
c'est que c'était ancré dans les
territoires donc finalement vous avez je
dis pas que c'est la seule explication
mais une explication assez forte de
cette dynamique qu'on observe je pense
toutes et tous à cet égard et on a
aujourd'hui une nouvelle technologie qui
arrive qui est finalement une sorte de
de de de de de phénomène exacerbé de
cette notion de euh de chisme c'estàd
que c'est une technologie qui est
exogène qui vient généralement
d'Amérique le son corpus général c'est
de l'anglais là-dessus les gens qui sont
à l'aise avec là c'est des gens qui sont
vraiment très largement formés dans le
supérieur qui évoluent dans le monde
tertièire et donc la première chose moi
qui me frappe c'est que ce type de de
technologie et de nature à renforcé
cette polarisation il se trouve que
c'est c'est pas toujours la même
approche que de parler de son son vécu à
soi mais j'ai passé un mois moi à me
balader dans dans le des des territoires
très rurau pendant cet été et j'ai eu
l'occasion de discuter avec des MRES de
petits villages et cetera et j'ai été
frappé de voir à quel point quand je
disais que je travaillais dans
l'intelligence artificielle euh les gens
le ressentait comme une menace cette
menace elle s'exprime principalement sur
deux thèmes c'est le thème du travail le
risque déclassement le fait se retrouver
avec encore moins de travail que il y en
avait auparavant et de plus faible
mobilité
sociale à cet égard puis l'autre aspect
qui est une peur plus générique de quand
on ne comprend pas la nature de cette
technologie c'est le fait que la machine
puisse faire du mal aux gens c'està-dire
qu'elle devienne autonome qu'elle ait
potentiellement une conscience propre eu
et et qu'elle s'affronte aux gens alors
qu'est-ce qu'il en est à l'égard de ces
deux peurs euh la première c'est l'enjeu
de la productivité je vousi expliqué que
tout à l'heure il y avait vraiblement
beaucoup de productivité au sein de ces
technologie je je ne vous cache pas que
on ne sait pas du tout quelle est la
quantité de productivité qui sera
disponible si vous écoutez certains
médecins urologues plus personne n'a de
travail de main je suis pas du tout sur
cette thèse notamment parce que tirer
les traits c'est très dangereux il y a
beaucoup d'enjeux de discontinuité dans
dans le développement de ces de de de
ces modèles et puis on voit des limites
très fortes au fonctionnement de ces
modèles aujourd'hui qu'on ne sait pas
forcément bien comment on va les
dépasser on peut supposer qu'on a des
gains de productivité substantiel mais
loin d'être infini à l'égard de de cette
technologie lorsque on s'intéresse
à l'histoire de l'économie historien que
j'aime beaucoup qui s'appelle Paul David
qui a travaillé sur finalement le le
schisme entre la première et la deè
révolution industrielle ce qu'on voit
c'est que en gros on commence à avoir
des problèmes quand les technologies
sont très brutales c'est quand le
système social le système de formation
professionnelle n'arrive pas à s'adapter
si la technologie arrive extrêmement
rapidement on va avoir des
zonees où on va avoir des déclassements
et au contraire plutôt une destruction
net de valeur d'ensemble que une
captation de ces gains de productivité
par l'ensemble du du corps productif et
de toutes ces souscomposantes je vais
pas rentrer dans le détail de ça parce
que ça ça prendrait un petit peu de
temps
mais c'est ce que l'on constate et donc
ce qui est vraiment important dans cette
affaire c'est de faire en sorte que
finalement les différentes composant du
système productif s'en empart se forme
et qu'on fasse en sorte que de la TPE à
la grande entreprise il y ait vraiment
une sorte de de prise de conscience
collective à cet égard et je dirais que
à mon sens c'est quasiment un enjeu
majeur de la société c'estàdire que vous
pouvez pas juste aller voir les chefs
d'entreprise et leur dire bon ben il
faut que vous vous intéressiez à
l'intelligence artificielle ça ne
fonctionnera pas c'est que ce qu'il faut
c'est qu'on ait une compréhension
collective de ce qu'est l'intelligence
artificielle personement je milite
depuis maintenant un an pour la mise en
place d' un dispositif qu'on appelle
caféia qui vise à aller parler avec 15
millions de Français d'intelligence
artificielle parce que nous pensons que
soit c'est un élan collectif et qui nous
permet de nous réemparer de ces
technologies qui sont je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure
exogène et de faire en sorte que plutôt
que d'avoir une orientation qui est
l'orientation que que d'autres ont défin
euh qui fasse en sorte que ce soit une
technologie qui nous soit propre mais
pour qu'elle nous nous soit propre il
faut qu'on décide de ce que l'on veut en
faire nous-mêm euh et le le champ du
possible est extrêmement vaste moi je
dis assez souvent que me semble-t-il et
vous l'avez évoqué ces technologies en
général ont été orienté dans une logique
extrêmement
consumériste les gains de productivité
qu'on a eu au cours des 50 dernières
années ont été quasiment tous
réinvestis dans un accroissement de du
potentiel de de de de consommation pas
toujours en bien d'ailleurs et là
aujourd'hui on a quand même une
technologie de productivité qui arrive à
un moment où on a un enjeu majeur qui
s'appelle la transition environnementale
donc ce qu'on sait c'est que ça va nous
coûter entre TR et quat points de PIP
par an jusqu'en 2050 c'est de l'argent
que personne n'a sur terre peut-être à
par les
cataris avec des moyens qui sont pas
forcément les plus écologiques qu' soit
et donc finalement soit on on dit bah on
va faire des efforts de redistribution
majeur ce qui peut poser ça dépend
jusqu'où on va mais dans certains cas ça
frottement peut être relativement
important so on se dit finalement on a
des gains de productivité et ces gains
de productivité plutôt que de les
réinvestir dans le consumérisme on va
les tourner vers cette transition et et
je crois que je n'insisterai jamais
assez sur l'opportunité qu'il y a
d'avoir finalement ces deux phénomènes
de façon simultanée je pense que c'est
vraiment une chance qu'il faut saisir et
j'irai même un peu plus loin j'observe
que la France est un pays où l'expertise
environmentale est assez forte c'est que
vous avez en France des grands acteurs
de l'environnement des sorts des violia
des suè je pour en compter une quinzaine
comme ça vous avez une énergie qui est
pratiquement par les plus décarboné au
monde grâce au
nucléaire et de ce fait si on arrive à
repenser notre système productif à l'Ô
de de de de de de ce nouveau paradigme
mais je pense que on a trois facteurs
qui nous poussent à penser que on peut
être au milieu du du jeu euh la qualité
de l'énergie et avec l'émergence de taxe
carbone aux frontières de l'Europe ça se
transforme tout à coup en opportunité
parce qu'on a une capacité de production
qui est tout à fait décarbonée la
localisation géographique on est au cœur
de l'Europe et donc si on crée des supl
chînes modernes qui sont bien intégrés
on a un potentiel de de
réindustrialisation qui est qui est fort
puis le troisème facteur c'est un
facteur qui est que les usines de demain
il y avait un papier dans les écho il y
a TR qu jours là-dessus sont des usines
qui sont non manufacturières c'estàdire
que qu'on le veille ou non c'est un peu
comme l'agriculture 80 % de l'emploi il
y a 200 ans aujourd'hui aux alentour de
2 % de l'emploi l'industrie c'est la
même chose c'est amené à être totalement
non manufacturier ça veut pas dire que
c'est des structures netes d'emploi mais
les emplois sont des emplois de service
de service à l'industrie qui sont autour
aour de ça et ça c'est ce qui amène
l'intelligence artificielle voilà le le
ce que je voulais dire à cet égard mais
encore une fois je pense que il y a une
vraie opportunité pour la France de se
positionner sur ces enjeuxl les
Allemands sont dans une situation panade
noire avec leur choix énergétique mais
aussi avec leur contexte démographique
et puis aussi avec leur sulashen qui
sont très intégrés sur les pays de l'Est
Biélorussie
Ukraine Russie
euh en particulier et et donc voilà il a
il y a une fenêtre à mon sens et qui est
très proche de cette idée de
d'intelligence artificielle à saisir
alors évidemment le troisème volet c'est
l'enjeu de la sphère
publique le le sujet est assez
vaste mais il y a je peux pas le couvrir
en entier je vous dirais que pour vous
il y a quelques grands enjeux euh qui
qui ont été d'ailleurs soulevés en
partie par l'
Act le le nouveau
règlement européen qui a été annoncé par
Thierry Breton
vendredi dernier c'est finalement quel
fonctionnement de la sphère publique
dans une perspective de l'intelligence
artificielle alors le premier enjeu à
mon sens
c'est ce qu'on appelle euh les les
services paramétriques ou le Crédit
social suivant là où on se place crédit
social c'est ce modèle chinois vous en
avez entendu parler vous traversez le
feu rouge moi je l'ai vu de mes yeux
j'ai vraiment vu de mes yeux baladant
avec un copain chinois à chenzen vous
êtes passé au rouge vous arrivez de
l'autre côté du feu vous avez
l'équivalent d' 1 € d'amende vous nêtes
pas encore de l'autre côté vous avez
déjà reçu l'alerte qui vous dit que vous
avez un dollar d'amende donc ce truc
existe mais si vous voulez dans les ACT
il y dit explicitement qu'on a pas le
droit de faire ça en réalité c'est déjà
partout c'est que quand vous roulez sur
l'autoroute que vous êtes à 90 km/h au
lieu de 80 enfin pas sur l'autoroute
mais voilà c'est c'est un système qui
est paramétrique qui est automatisé et
en France ça n'est pas encore le cas
mais dans les pays scandinaves l'accès
au droit est automatisé c'estd que vous
recevez de l'argent l'équivalent du RSA
sur votre relevé de compte vous n'avez
rien demander on a rapproché vos données
sociales de vos données fiscales et on
vous le donne de façon automatique euh
je je il y a tout un tas de de parcours
sub c'est un système
paramétrique l'algorithme de la CAF dont
on parle beaucoup ces jours-ci c'est un
système paramétrique ces systèmes sont
amenés qu'on le veille ou non à envahir
la sphère publ pour des questions de
productivité des services publics et la
question qu'il faut se poser c'est pas
de savoir si on doit les interdire ou
pas c'est comment on peut garantir
l'équité des sititoy citoyen face à ce
genre de choses
et je rien que ce sujet pourrait nous
occupé pendant une partie de
l'après-midi mais mon
sentiment pour avoir quand même beaucoup
travaillé là-dessus notamment à la
Commission européenne où j'étais en
charge d'une partie de ces sujets j'ai
visité quasiment 24 des des 28 à
l'époque pays membres pour échanger sur
ces sujets c'est que à moyen terme il
nous faudra une évolution force forte
des institutions publiques pour faire en
sorte que les citoyens ne fassent plus
face à l'état mais soitent au cœur de
l'État et au cœur de la construction de
l'État et que finalement les garants
Infiné du fait que il y aura un maintien
de l'équité face à ces modèles et bien
ce seront les citoyens qui auront accès
à la transparence des algorithmes qui
veilleront à ce que ces algorithmes ne
soient pas discriminants d'ailleurs
cette dynamique elle est partiellement
enclenchée open fisca c'est le moteur de
de calcul fiscal il est en open source
c'est-à-dire moi vous on peut tous y
accéder on peut regarder dedans on peut
chercher savoir si il crée pas des
niches fiscales et puis si il crée pas
ben de l'inéquité des uns et des autres
par rapport à euh au au système fiscal
c'est la même chose pour parcours sup et
pour de plus en plus des gros morceaux
de de code euh de l'État donc ça c'est
un premier pas mais le deuxème pas c'est
de faire en sorte que on construise des
institutions qui
intègre des citoyens qui puissent être
des coproducteurs des services
publics sous une forme de de réserve
civique et qui soit capable finalement
de faire en sorte que d'une part on
coproduise donc il a l'usager soit tout
le temps dans la boucle et ça c'est une
des explications de pourquoi les 250
services publics aujourd'hui sont si
critiquer parce qu'on n pas mis l'usager
dans la boucle dès le départ et puis
d'autre part cré de la confiance en
réalité c'estd que l'une des raisons de
la défiance c'est que ça se passe à
Paris ça se passe de façon opaque et
quand vous allez dans les territoire
c'est évidemi j'ai fait des débats sur
la 5G sur le compte link key euh le
reproche sous-jacent c'est que c'est
centralisme et verticalité voilà donc ça
c'est très très présent dans le dans le
débat et je pense qu'il nous appartient
de de faire en sorte que on soit capable
de le dépasser encore une fois je pense
que ce sujet de de de l'intelligence
artificielle nature a soit on choisit de
renforcer centralisme et on se plantera
soit on en profite pour dire ok
finalement ce ce ce débat qui est
finalement extrêmement emblématique des
peurs qu'on peut avoir sur le climat sur
tout un tas d'évolutions géopolitiques
et cetera et bien on peut on peut faire
en sorte que on passe de la peur à la
compréhension à une culture collective
et qu'on décide ensemble de ce que l'on
puisse faire quelques mots rapidement
sur les trois sujets que vous avez
évoqué qui sont territoire éducation et
santé
euh sur les les les territoires je l'ai
dit on a un enjeu qui une grande
complexité c'estàd faire en sorte que
d'abord on nit pas de Gap entre l'accès
au services public
et ce qui se passe à l'intérieur des des
grandes
métropoles la question c'est de savoir
comment se positionne l'intelligence
artificielle à cet égard je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure je pense que et moi j'ai
j'ai fait des d'ailleurs des auditions
dans ce cadre là qui était absolument
vraiment vertigineuse euh a priori ce on
dit souvent que l'une des des aspects de
l'intelligence artificielle c'est sa
capacité à évoluer au travers de langage
naturel et vous voyez bien il y a eu une
une comment dire
une une augmentation de la qualité de la
reconnaissance vocale qui est beaucoup
plus importante
et le il y a deux choses que peut nous
procurer ces système de large langage
modèle première c'est la capacité
d'interaction dans la communication
c'est des communication qui vont devenir
et qui sont en train de le devenir
d'après ce que je vois il y a un petit
retard sur la le français par rapport à
l'anglais mais qui est de quelques
semaines parce que les il y a plus de de
le corpus en anglais est plus nombreux
sur le sur internet mais néanmoins je
sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais moi
je parle littéralement
à gpt4 en conversation normal si vous
utilisez zoom et que vous demandez à
zoom de vous faire un compte-rendu à la
fin deun réunion il y avait une
vingtaine de de personnees vous allez
voir la qualité du compte-rendu est
stupéfiante elle est vraiment de très
très bonne qualité et donc dans
l'interaction avec des services publics
ça va augmenter et puis l'autre
caractéristique des LLM c'est B ce que
je vous disais tout à l'heure c'est
d'être capable de souder des expériences
qui sont aujourd'hui exprimées en silo
c'est que si vous avez un service public
où on vous demande d'aller chercher des
données ou des documents qui sont dans
la la sphère sociale et puis dans la
sphère fiscale et cetera et bien le la
machine A priori est capable d'intégrer
tout ça et de le faire ça dépend des
implémentations mais dans une forme de
respect euh de l'utilisation de vos
données personnelles alors je ne dis pas
que c'est ce qu'on va faire il y a tout
un tas de
de de de défis qu'il faudra dépasser
pour pouvoir faire ça mais si on en
avait la volonté on a une vraie
opportunité de rapprocher euh
l'expérience des services publics des
des citoyens où qui se trouve et à mon
sens c'est une opportunité qui est très
supérieure à celle du numérique parce
que la promesse du numérique c'était
celle-là au départ il y a 20 ans on
disait bah on va tout faire sur internet
ça va être super bien pour tout le monde
en réalité on a éloigné les gens des
services publics c'est le constat qu'on
peut faire à cet égard voilà ce que je
je dirais à ce sujet sur sur le plan de
la santé alors on a effectivement t vu
les publications dans Nature sur la
qualité du diagnostic et c'est
indéniable euh sur tout ce qui est
imagerie on a déjà aujourd'hui augmenté
le diagnostic par
exemple sur la dermatologie on a une
qualité diagnostique qui est
systématiquement supérieure au médecin
c'est un
contesté il y a en noncologie on
commence à avoir des choses qui sont
supérieures on je pense qu'il faut pas
ce ce leurit c'est c'est assez facile
d'accès et ça ne bouleverse pas le
modèle pour une raison simple c'est que
avant très longtemps on va rester dans
des modèles supervisés c'est qu'à la fin
c'est le médecin qui décide euh parce
qu'on a quand même un se nombre de
risque à cet égard et puis parce que les
les machines et c'est une de leurs
grandes faiblesses sont incapables de
contextualisation elles ne comprennent
pas le contexte dans lequel ça se passe
est-ce que la personne qui est en face
de vous est capable
d'observance euh quels sont ses
conditions de vie voilà un médecin
comprend ces choseslà et et donc le le
le le diagnostic va être assisté très
fortement et c'est quelque chose qui est
en train d'asser d'entrer massivement
dans dans le système la question qui qui
à mon sens est première c'est face à la
crise hospitalière qui est une crise à
la fois de vocation de moyens et aussi
je pense
de changement du contexte ou le le
traitement de certaines pathologies
coûte plus cher notamment les cancers
est-ce que le machine learning va être
du N force alors je pense que oui mais à
moyen terme quand on regarde à la fois
en ville et à l'hôpital ce qui se passe
les études sont à peu près unanimes sur
ce sujet 30 % du temps c'est la
bureaucratie voilà c'est et d'ailleurs
quand vous allez voir votre médecin
c'est c'est horripilant il a son nez
dans l'ordinateur euh beaucoup plus que
il vous regarde dans les yeux et on a
tous cette expérience alors heureusement
ça lui fait pas
faire forcément perdre beaucoup de de
temps mais ça change quand même la
nature de la relation et ça peut altérer
la qualité du du
diagnostic à la fin je je pense que on a
une opportunité de
réduire notamment à l'hôpital le temps
qui est passé à faire des reportings à
l'adresse et à la hasas ou je ne sais
qui encore euh et euh c'est quelque
chose qui commence à arriver mais euh
qui est très largement contraint par euh
notre
transcription du volet santé du rgpd sur
lequel le législateur français a choisi
enfin je j'accuse personne de faire
ceinturer bretelle et qui rend la le le
mouvement dans cette direction un petit
peu difficile il y a rapport qui doit
sortir dans les jours qui viennent il me
semble c'est le varieux je ne sais plus
comment il me semble que c'est
l'exécutif qui a commander ce rapport
sur ce point précis je vous invite à en
prendre connaissance qui est quand même
assez dur sur à la fois la difficulté de
faire de la recherche et puis de
traiter des processus ce qu'on appelle
des workflow dans ce domaine encore une
fois je pense que à moyen terme on a
quand même la possibilité de d'avoir des
améliorations assez importantes
le risque étant que comme je le disais
tout à
l'heure on essaie de faire des
amélioration en gardant le système tel
qu'il existe si on veut que ces
améliorations fonctionnent il faut
accepter d'avoir des logiques de bac
àable c'est-à-dire on repense vraiment
l'ensemble du processus d'embarquement
du
patient et heureusement j'ai entendu
dire qu'il y avait quelques
expérimentations de ce type
là rapidement sur l'école et je finis
là-dessus on arrive dans un contexte qui
est celui de PISA données viennent de
sortir elles sont dramatiques même si on
n pas vraiment très grand déclassement
moi j'aurais pu espérer que comme on
avait pas fermé les écoles pendant le
covid finalement ça serait perc
répercuterait ben même pas on a plutôt
descendu un petit peu plus que les
autres grands pays de
l'OCDE et évidemment on est tous
conscients qu'il fauts c'est une
priorité nationale de de premier ordre
alors euh dans ce je vais pas rentrer
dans le cœur de ça parce qu'il là aussi
il y aurait beaucoup à dire je vais me
concentrer sur deux points euh de façon
assez arbitraire euh que relève l'équipe
de l'OCDE tant de formation des
professeurs il y a une corrélation
absolue entre le temps de formation des
professeurs et la performance dans PISA
euh les les quatre premiers dans PISA
donc c'est
euh Singapour je me souviens plus
Singapour la Corée euh il me semble la
Chine est 4e et puis il doit avoir
taiïwan l'Estonie c'est le premier
européen mais ils sont 8e il sont 9e
9e donc ces quatre grands pays la
caractéristique première qui ressort
c'est le temps de formation des
enseignants 100 heur par an versus 10 en
France voilà
et lorsqu'on essaie de comprendre
pourquoi est-ce que on a un delta trop
aussi important de de de
formation djusco vous répond euh ben
c'est très très difficile d'amener la
formation aux enseignants euh lorsqu'on
fait des mous qui les suivent pas et
cetera et cetera donc c'est c'est
vraiment difficile de faire ce genre de
chos je je ne dis pas que le
l'intelligence artificielle va résoudre
ce problème là mais ce qui est certain
c'est que par rapport au mou où vous
avez des taux d'attrition qui sont de 95
% c'est c'est très rare quelqu'un
finisse un mou c'est vraiment euh il
faut lui donner une médaille tout de
suite quelqu'un qui a réussi à faire un
mou et bien on observe alors c'est des
travaux qui sont plutôt préliminaires
mais que quand vous personnalisez
l'enseignement au travers d'une
conversation notamment la Fondation la
CAN Académie a fait des travaux assez
intéressants à cet égard vous avez des
taux d'observance on peut parler
d'observance qui sont très très
nettement supérieur donc ça c'est une
dynamique qui est intéressante puis le
deuxème deuxième paramètre qui a été
aussi mis en avant par PISA et qui moi
me me semble extrêmement
angoissant c'est la très faible mobilité
sociale du système scolaire c'est que
non seulement un système qui est pas
très qualitatif mais les gens
rentrent dans un milieu dans un contexte
très dégradé et sortent dans un contexte
dégradé et vous n'avez pas de
transversalité ou alors
exceptionnellement moins que dans les
autres pays et je veux dire finalement
pour un pays qui
a comme devise la notion de d'égalité je
pense que l'égalité des chances que
procure l'école c'est quand même quelque
chose auquel on devrait être soucieux et
quand on essaie de comprendre ce qui se
passe ben il y a un phénomène qu'on
explique pas très bien d'ailleurs mais
c'est euh le le ce qui se passe à
l'extérieur de l'école c'est que le le
le facteur de de de maintien euh dans sa
strate entre guillemets c'est le fait
que Ben les les parents de milieu aisé
passent plus de temps avec leurs enfants
parce que ils ont conditions pour le
faire ils leur payent plus de cours
particuliers et et ça c'est quelque
chose qui est assez
visible dans ce domaine parce que notre
organisation sociale fait ça on est on a
généralement tendance à beaucoup
incriminer l'école mais à moins regarder
son contexte or le contexte est un
surdéterminant extrêmement fort et à cet
égard et là jeen reviens à ce que
j'aiévoqué à l'égard de la CAN académie
la CAN Académie a fait euh un truc que
j'ai expérimenté qui est vraiment
remarquable vous pouvez aller sur leur
site je pense que c'est en ligne mais
euh vous avez des des des des
conversations avec des grands personnag
de l'histoire donc vous pouvez parler
avec Marie curry enfin tous ceux qui ont
beaucoup écrit parce qu'évidemment pour
qu'on alimente le modèle il faut que ils
aient beaucoup écrit euh donc on peut
même parler avec des gens qui sont euh
des quasi euh qu'on a on n'est pas sûr
qu'ils aent vraiment existé en tant que
tel comme Shakespeare euh mais euh donc
on a une représentation imagée de
Shakespear mais mais néanmoins comme il
a beaucoup écrit on peut avoir une
conversation avec Shakespeare et et donc
c'est assez bluffant parce que vous
pouvez mettre un enfant de 5 ans devant
Einstein comme vous pouvez mettre un
scientifique de de qui fait de
l'astrophysique de très très haut niveau
à cet égard
donc tout cela est extrêmement
prometteur mais repose sur un une
une une conditionnalité c'est que on
construisent l'ingénierie pédagogique
autour de ça voilà c'estàdire que on se
dise ok on a un outil qui est
potentiellement remarquable pour
assister les les les élèves lorsqu'ils
sont chez eux mais ça nous pousse à
repenser le processus pédagogique de
façon
forte et quelque chose qui est je trouve
de assez prometteur c'est le fait que
depuis quelques années la rue de
Grenelle est rentrée dans une logique
d'expérimentation tion à large échelle
c'est-à-dire vraiment d'avoir des tests
qui sont quasi randomisés c'està-dire
avec un double aveugle où on va prendre
100 classes puis on va faire une
expérimentation et puis si ça marche on
va essayer de l'étendre et donc ça c'est
quelque chose qui est de nature à à
donner quand même un peu d'espoir sur
notre capacité à à aller sortir les REP
du sonillon dans lequel elle se situe
voilà j'été un peu trop long mais
j'essayé de couvrir sombre des points
que vous avez
évoqué ce que je propose c'est qu'on
prenne toutes les questions et vous y
répondez parce qu'on a les questions au
Gouvernement qui vont venir et juste moi
je transition avec ce que vous disiez le
ministre de l'éducation nationale vient
de lancer enfin d'annoncer que tous les
élèves de Seconde bénéficieraient d'un
sorte de de cours particulier enfin de
tutorat par intelligence artificielle à
la rentrée prochaine est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est bien ou pas bien à vous
écouter j'ai envie de dire que c'est pas
suffisant parce queon ne repense pas la
pédagogie voà voilà je pose ça sur la
table qui d'autre veut
oui nousavons pas évoqué c'est et qui je
pense est au cœur de nos préoccupations
c'est
notre souveraineté sur le sujet
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous pensez que
par exemple dernière exemple en date
c'est c'est mistralï qui qui vient
d'être intégré dans dans le camp des
licornes mais est-ce que le le retard
n'est pas déjà rattrapable ou est-ce
qu'effectivement on est en capacité euh
contrairement au Cloud par exemple de
pouvoir demain être au niveau et et ne
pas accuser le retard que l'on a accusé
sur quasiment toutes les innovations de
rupture qu'on a eu jusque- là
oui merci pour pour votre exposé donc
une question très courte euh alors il
semblerait mais vous allez le le
confirmer ou l'infirmer que au niveau de
l'intelligence artificielle ou
l'automatisation numérique appelonsla
comme on veut il y a est malgré tout des
biais qui peuvent induire certaines
réponses et comment pensez-vous que
qu'on puisse agir à ce niveau pour pour
les éviter
et et tout ce qui ça peut induire en
conséquence merci pareilement une
question très courte vous l'avez évoqué
tout à l'heure vous avez évoqué une
crainte qui était souvent exprimé sur le
contrôle sur sur l'intelligence
artificielle vous avez évoqué et moi je
trouve ça passionnant hein tous les
usages qu'on en fait déjà aujourd'hui et
qu'on en fera demain ma question est
très simple hein c'est que répondez-vous
à ceux qui nous qui se pose la question
de savoir comment garder la main en fait
sur sur cet outil
merci vous avz une question pas non ou
oui
alors euh juste sur le merci infiniment
pour votre présentation juste sur le
dernier point de
l'enseignement est-ce que le sujet avant
effectivement de de repenser
l'ingénierie pédagogique et on voit bien
tout le potentiel qu'il y a devant c'est
de former les enfants dès le plus jeune
âge au codagege de les former à la
maîtrise de ces outils parce que je
pense que tout ce que vous dites après
sur la façon dont on peut repenser les
services publics en intégrant les
usagers parce que pour l'instant les
usagers c'est mettre des étoiles et
répondre à des questionnaires débiles
sur on est content on n'est pas content
du
service mais au fond c'est d'abord faire
de nos enfants des citoyens en capacité
de maîtriser ces outils là parce que
personne va les voir dans les
algorithmes donc donc faut déjà
comprendre ce que c'est qu'un algorithme
ok je je vais aller
vite je suis d'accord avec vous je je
suis assez circonspect sur ce qu' le
ministre a annoncé sur son modèle de
langage c'est ça sent je je pense pas
qu'il Chatam house ici mais ça sent
quand même beaucoup le la notion
d'annonce enfin fait comme pour le dire
assez franchement c'estd que c'est disp
non' aucun sens s' s'inscrivent pas dans
un contexte voilà c'est mon point de vue
c'est comme ça sur sur votre point
écoutez je suis assez ambivalent
là-dessus c'est que quand vous parlez
avec des professeurs il vous dis écoutez
quand vous parlez avec le CDE d'illeurs
le CDE vous dit une des caractéristiques
du système français je parle de l'école
primaire c'est que il y a 48 disciplines
la recommandation de l'OCDE c'est 15
alors si vous voulez tout le monde y va
de son truc on va mettre des cours de
laïcité on va mettre des cours de code
on va mettre des trucs moi je vais vous
dire je prêcher pour ma chapppelle je
vais dire on va faire des cours d'IA des
cours de code et cetera je je je ne sais
pas j'ai l'impression que quand même ce
qui donne le plus de capacité si ce qui
encapacite les enfants c'est quand même
de savoir lire écrire et conter au
départ quoi et il me semble-t-il tant
que l'école n'aura pas réussi cette
mission je mettrai quand même en second
rang je sais combien c'est préoccupant
de sensibiliser les enfants aux enux de
for informations avoir un code de
conduite sur les réseaux sociaux et on
voit tous les drames qu'on a tous les
jours du fait que ils disent n'importe
quoi et que discours de haine se se se
se
propage je je voilà je navigue entre ces
deux points là euh et mon inflexion
c'est quand même de une fois qu'on aura
résolu le problème de base ce qui donne
de la mobilité on peut se préoccuper de
ce ce point-là mais sur le fond vous
vous avez fondamentalement raison euh
sur cet aspect là juste un petit point
vous remettez un enseignement en silo en
fait tout ce que vous nous expliquez sur
l'intelligence artificielle c'est le
principe des plateformes et là y compris
cet apprentissage là ce serait un un
apprentissage de plus je pense que c'est
ce qui ce qui vous permet d'aller vers
cet apprentissage de plus c'est d'être à
l'aise en société et ce qui vous permet
d'être à l'aise en société c'est de
savoir vous exprimer de savoir lire
écrire et compter voilà je je suis je
suis c'est un débat éternel vous savez
entre les
holistiques les spécialisé j'ai tendance
à moi je men remets beaucoup à l'OCDE
parce que je pense que ils ont une telle
capacité de comparaison sur ce qui se
passe et de recommandation les pays qui
les ont suivi l'Allemagne elle a pris h
places en disant on va appliquer
strictement ce que dit PISA 8 places
depuis 2000 dans l'OCDE nous on en a
perdu
trois donc voilà
petit point vous avez tout à fait raison
sur le le r le petit questionnaire à la
fin du service public c'est totalement
biaisant parce que on répond au
questionnaire une fois qu'on a accompli
la procédure donc c'est n'importe quoi
quoi c'est tous les gens qui arrivent
sur la première page et qui abandonnent
ils sont pas comptés voilà donc quand
vous lisez dans le l'Observatoire des
services publics tel service est à 95 %
de T satisfaction c'est n'importe quoi
en réalité et ça mérite d'être dit parce
que c'est un bien méthodologique
fondamental euh sur la la la
souveraineté alors je sais pas si vous
le savez mais c'est un sujet sur lequel
j'ai beaucoup travaillé
encore hier j'ai publié un papier dans
les écho sur euh ce sujet je suis je ve
dire je vais faire un résumé extrêmement
court mais la souveraineté ça se regagne
comme ça s'est perdu en 40 ans c'estàd
que on a fait n'importe quoi euh sur le
système productif qui était quand même
de bon niveau il y a 40 ans on l'a
détruit j'ai évoqué C part de PIB
industriel ce qu'il en est devenu euh on
est en train de peut-être faire un un
début de demi-tour à cet égard euh ça
prendra très longtemps et il faut se
méfier euh des recettes de court terme
qui consistent à dire en fait faire du
protectionnisme on va faire je ne sais
quoi c'est voilà c'est il faut accepter
qu'on a perdu cette souveraineté en très
large partie
euh après il faut relativiser aussi même
les Américains aujourd'hui ne sont pas
souverains c'est-à-dire que ils fondent
pas leurs composants majeurs un certain
nombre de technologies ne sont pas chez
eux et et et donc ce qui compte c'est de
comprendre de quoi sont faites ces
chaînes d'approvisionnement et de
renforcer les points faibles je je pense
important de le dire à l'échelle
nationale ça me semble impossible voilà
c'est l'espace européen et d'ailleurs
les constructeurs automobiles vous le
disent ils sont en train de rapatrier
leur chaîne de valeur pour les mettre à
peu près sur une périmétrie qui est
espace européen plus Maroc et Turquie en
gros et c'est la même chose dans
l'automobile dans le pardon dans
l'aéronautique
eu sur les biais euh c'est un un vaste
débat sur les biais mais aujourd'hui le
ce qui est très à la mode et j'ai pas eu
le temps de parler des différentes
formes d'intelligence artificielle mais
c'est les larges modèles les larges
modèles sont fascinants parce
que c'est un peu comme ils sont capables
d'aller sur n'importe quelle thématique
avec une grande efficacité et en fait
euh telle thématique renforce l'autre
c'estàdire que vous le fait de vous
intéresser par exemple au courant marin
vous permet de renforcer la
compréhension du climat
euh ou de la météo par exemple et donc
ça le machine est capable de faire des
corrélations que nous ne savons pas
faire et d'ailleurs on voit que les
larges modèles sont beaucoup plus
puissants à faire de la météo que les
systèmes spécialisés sur laquelle on a
investi des centaines de millions de
d'euros dans des des
institutions européenne mais le BET de
ça c'est que vous avez des
hallucinations et j'en parlais avec des
grands experts des Luc Julia des Yan
Lequin qui me disaient problème qu'on a
c'est que on a arrivera pas à réduire
ces
hallucinations probablement en dessous
de quelques pourcents et ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire que les les LLM ce qui
est vraiment à la mode aujourd'hui vont
pour être utilisé devoir être supervisé
toujours c'estàd que ça va jamais être
des systèmes automatiques qui prendront
eux-mêmes les décisions donc vous
pourriez par exemple avoir des systèmes
qui analysent je sais pas les
déclarations fiscales des gens de façon
totalement automatisé puis qui disent
bah on vous redresse on vous redresse
pas je sais pas ce genre de chose on le
fera pas avec des LLM c'est pas possible
parce que les risques sont trop
importants de faire ce genre de chose le
véhicule autonome n'est pas du tout à
base de de LLM donc vous avez les
systèmes qui sont maîtrisés qui sont
plutôt des systèmes verticalisés
notamment pour tout ce qui est
séquentiel et puis vous avez des
systèmes qui sont extrêmement puissants
mais avec un risque d'hallucination qui
est assez significative j'ajoute que ces
technologies peuvent aussi être
utilisées et vous l'avez compris pour
faire la désinformation des fausses
images pour synchroniser des armées de
troll et déstabiliser une élection par
exemple euh c'est une des grandes
craintes qu'on a quand je parle avec les
gens de viginum c'est c'est leur grande
crainte et ça arrivera certainement à
l'occasion des des grandes élections
mais on a quand même un coup d'avance
c'est-à-dire que B comme ces
technologies sont open source sont
répartis mais il y a beaucoup de gens
qui s'intéressent à comment est-ce qu'on
fait des des syè système de contremesure
notamment dans le monde cyber pour
éviter le la la prise de contrôle de de
de de ces systèmes
euh sur la notion de perte de contrôle
par rapport à à l'intelligence
artificielle je pense que ça vous vous
évoquez cette notion de intelligence
artificielle générale dont on parle
beaucoup dans la presse il faut se
méfier de euh journalistes qui
finalement trouvent un sujet facile pour
évoquer quelque chose que là aussi les
les les gens qui sont un peu des experts
dégagés de conflit d'intérêt donc en
d'utres termes qui ne sont pas samalman
les gens qui ont intérêt à amener le
projecteur sur eux vous disent il y a
aucune aujourd'hui autre base que la
science-fiction pour nous dire que c'est
dispositifs vont exister on va avoir des
systèmes qui vont monter en puissance on
sait pas quand gpt5 va sortir mais prob
dans les dans les prochains mois je
pense que ça sera assez stupéfiant mais
euh pour cl le débat je dirais que
aujourd'hui aucune de ces machines ne
passe et de très loin ce qu'on appelle
le test de Turing c'est le fait d'avoir
une conversation avec une machine
capable plus capable de dire si vous
parlez avec un être humain ou avec une
machine on l'a fait passer à 150 élèves
de de de de Stanford et à 94 % ils ont
trouvé qu'ils étaient face à une machine
ou un être humain quand c'était le
cas enfin excusez-moi ce que je dis
surtout en fait au travers de ma
question c'est l'enjeu
de pédagogie de démocratisation en fait
du sujet c'est je vous disais en fait ma
question c'était de dire que répondt-on
à cela j'ai bien conscience en fait de
la réponse mais c'est surtout l'énorme
enjeu vous dites les messages sont
simples simplifiés mais mais mais
l'enjeu il est très très fort au sein de
notre population mais alors et ça je
pourrais répondre à Yan jade c'estd que
autant moi je j'ai tendance à dire il
faut sacraliser les enseignements qui
créent de la mobilité sociale autant je
pense que il faut créer un mécanisme et
moi j'ai plutôt tendance à dire que ça
touche évidemment les les les les les
jeunes enfants mais aussi tous les
Français et donc nous encore une fois
moi je je propose et je me bats pour je
vous dire je va tout dans tous les
ministères partout euh je voudrais créer
ce mécanisme qui soit un mécanisme
vraiment de proximité caféia o on va
parler à 15 millions de Français
d'intelligence artificielle et dans un
cas euh à Madame Michu on va dire on va
la rassurer sur le fait que son
Petitfils va pas perdre sans boulot dans
l'autre on va lui expliquer que
justement ces machines vont pas devenir
conscientes au patron de TPE on va lui
expliquer comment il peut se servir de
l'intelligence artificielle pour mieux
gérer certaines choses et et un gamin de
14 ans on va lui dire qu'il peut en
faire son métier voilà et au-delà de ça
je je j'ai vraiment cette conviction
c'est que on peut C ces technologies
n'ont pas pour vocation à devenir ce
qu'est le modèle américain c'est un
modèle hyper intensif sur le plan du
capital euh avec une une finalité très
consumériste on peut faire quelque chose
de
différent ou consumérisme ou société de
surveillance qui sont quand même les
deuxou mais et d'ailleurs je je vous
l'ai dit moi je pense que on évitera ça
à partir du moment on repensera
l'interaction des si les citoyens sont
la boucle il y a moins de
risque une bonne piste de travail pour
nous puisque c'est un peu le tout
l'enjeu c'est de montrer qu'en 2050 2070
on vivra avec l'intelligence
artificielle mais en bonne
entente bien avant bien avant je
pense pas
encore